Grafica "y" igual a 2 entre 7 por "x".
Y además responde, ¿cuáles de las siguiente
proposiciones son verdaderas?
Bueno, tenemos esta gráfica que tenemos que
ajustar para que se adecue a esta ecuación.
Ésta es una relación proporcional, porque
es de la forma "y" igual a una constante,
en este caso 2 entre 7 por "x".
Su gráfica va a ser una línea recta, pero
primero vamos a graficar la ecuación.
Y tenemos que encontrar dos puntos que pertenezcan
a esta ecuación.
¿Qué pasa si yo aquí pongo "x" igual a 0?
Pues el valor de "y" va a ser igual a 0, así
que pongo esto aquí en 0, 0.
Muy bien, necesito otro punto, quiero encontrar
un punto de "y" que sea entero y me convenga,
esa es una fracción y bueno, pues para poder
quitar esa fracción
me conviene que "x" sea igual a 7, para que se cancele con el denominador aquí.
Y si "x" es 7, esto se cancela y me queda
que "y" es igual a 2, así que aquí busco
así que aquí busco "x" igual a 7, "y" igual a 2.
Y esa es la gráfica de mi ecuación.
Bueno, ahora vamos a ver los enunciados,
estas proposiciones.
La primera, la ecuación representa
una relación proporcional.
Ésta es verdadera, ya lo habíamos establecido
por el formato que tiene esta ecuación.
Así que ésta es verdadera.
La segunda, la tasa de cambio unitaria de
"y" con respecto a "x" es 7/2.
Veamos, la tasa de cambio unitaria de "y"
con respecto a "x" es el valor de "y"
que corresponde a "x" igual a 1, así que la tasa
de cambio unitaria si "x" sustituye aquí
igual a 1, pues va a ser 2/7 y aquí nos dice
que es 7/2, lo cual no es correcto,
ésta no es verdadera.
La pendiente de la recta es 2/7, esto es evidente,
ya que esta ecuación es la de una recta,
tiene el formato de manera que este factor
que multiplica a "x" y que todo es igual a
"y", es la ecuación de una recta, así que
ésta es verdadera.
Veamos la siguiente, un cambio de 7 unidades
en "x"... como ésta, 7 unidades en "x"...
resulta en un cambio de 2 unidades en "y",
y aquí lo estamos viendo, tenemos aquí...
nos movimos 7 lugares en "x" y al mismo tiempo
recorrimos 2 lugares en "y",
así que ésta también es verdadera.
La última, un cambio de 6 unidades en "x"
resulta en un cambio de 21 unidades en "y".
Veamos, si me muevo aquí en "x" 6 unidades,
"y" no va a valer 21, para nada,
"y" va a valer 1.8 ó 1.9, algo así,
entonces ésta es falsa.
Comprobamos la respuesta y en efecto,
ésta es correcta.